Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft, mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zu 29. Ausgabe der Gesprächsserie über Wissenschaft, über wissenschaftliche Fragen und immer wieder auch mal über sehr konkrete wissenschaftliche Arbeit. Und das ist unser Fokus heute ein wenig. Und wir tauchen ein im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, denn wir konzentrieren uns auf das Meer und auch ein wenig auf das große Meer, die Tiefsee, wir wollen über Meeresforschung sprechen und über Expeditionen und die ganzen Fragen, die damit verbunden sind. Und als Gesprächspartnerin dafür begrüße ich Angelika Brandt, schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag Herr Pritlove, freut mich, dass Sie mich heute interviewen zu dem Thema Meeresforschung und Tiefsee.
Ja das freut mich auch sehr. Denn Sie sind ja auch ein sehr geeigneter Gesprächspartner dafür, Sie sind Meeresbiologin. Wir befinden uns jetzt gerade hier in Hamburg an der Universität Hamburg, konkret in dem CeNak, dem Zentrum für Naturkunde. Was nicht nur ein Ausbildungsort ist, sondern wie ich auch gerade festgestellt habe, auch ein Ort der Öffentlichkeit. Denn gleich, wenn man hier reinspaziert kommt, begrüßen einen große Grizzlybären und Gnus und was da nicht noch alles rumsteht. Wie lange gibt es dieses Museum schon dort unten?
Das ist eigentlich ein Wiederaufbau eines ursprünglich sehr großen Naturkundemuseums, was 1919 gebaut wurde und unten am Steintorwall stand. Das ist 1943 dann ausgebombt worden, hatte aber vorm zweiten Weltkrieg eigentlich eine sehr große Bedeutung in Deutschland. War damals das zweitbedeutendste Museum und hatte sehr sehr viele Besucher. Also es steht dort, wo jetzt Saturn und Hansa ist, dieses Gebäude. Die Schausammlung unten, an der Sie vorbei gegangen sind, ist 1984 wieder etabliert worden, um den Studierenden einfach und auch der Öffentlichkeit hier in Hamburg einen Blick eben in die Zoologie, in unsere Forschung zu geben und ein Teil der vielen Objekte, die hier eigentlich hinter den Kulissen verborgen sind, eben auch der Öffentlichkeit zugänglich zu machen. Also das zoologische Museum ist eines der größten in Deutschland und beherbergt ca. 10 Millionen Objekte hinter den Kulissen, die eben in den verschiedenen Räumen, in einen haben Sie ja eben gerade reingeschaut, versteckt sind.
Ja das sind diese ominösen gut klimatisierten Räume mit – in was sind die Objekte in der Regel eingelegt?
Sie sind meist in Alkohol sozusagen fixiert und dadurch eben auch für die nächsten Forschergenerationen wissenschaftlich nutzbar. Das heißt also wirklich für nachhaltige Biodiversitätsforschung auch in 500 Jahren noch verwendbar.
Sie sind ja die stellvertretende Leiterin des Zentrums für Naturkunde, aber auch konkret für den Bereich wirbellose Tiere zuständig? Welche sind das?
Das sind alles die, die keine Wirbelsäule haben. Also es geht im Prinzip von den Schwämmen bis hin zu den Stachelhäutern. Die Tierstämme, die hier vertreten sind. Wir teilen uns das mit mehreren Kollegen auf. Wir haben eine Malakologie, die mit Weichtieren sich beschäftigt, die Entomologie, die Abteilung, die sich eben mit den Insekten beschäftigt. Arachnologie, die Spinnentiere. Ein Kollege von mir leitet die Abteilung Invertebraten, also wirbellose eins. Bei mir die wirbellosen zwei. Bei mir sind vor allem die Krebstiere und die Meeresborstenwürmer, so zwei Tiergruppen, die mit sehr sehr viel Typusmaterial hier vorliegen am zoologischen Museum, und das bedeutet, dass wenn eine Art zum Beispiel neu beschrieben wird, wenn man in einen Lebensraum fährt, der relativ unbekannt ist – das passiert in der Tiefsee oder in den Baumkronenregionen tropischer Regenwälder zum Beispiel – dass man eben immer wieder auf Arten trifft, die überhaupt noch gar keinen Namen haben und eigentlich für die Wissenschaft nicht existent sind. Und dann kann man sie beschreiben. Dann wenn sie wissenschaftlich eine große Bedeutung haben zum Beispiel für die Evolutionsforschung oder die geografische Forschung.
Und dann muss man sie eben genau dokumentieren, und das Objekt, das tatsächlich dann namensgebend ist, in einem zoologischen Museum in Hamburg oder irgendwo anders in der Welt hinterlegen. Das heißt unsere zoologischen Museen und so etwas wie Datenbanken, also im Prinzip wie Büchereien der Natur, in der man dann tatsächlich auch immer die Referenz zu dem ersten Objekt einer Art, die beschrieben worden ist, hat. Und es sind insofern Zeit-, Raum- und Gendatenbanken. Zeit, zu dem Zeitpunkt, an dem sie gesammelt wurden, haben sie ein bestimmte Lokalität gehabt, die Tiere hatten dann eine Verbreitung, nämlich dort wo wir sie gefunden haben. Und es ist teilweise so, dass wir eben heute Arten bei uns in den Sammlungen haben, die dort aber schon gar nicht mehr vorkommen, weil sie von anderen Arten verdrängt wurden oder weil sie ausgestorben sind und überhaupt gar nicht mehr existieren. Insofern sind unsere Bibliotheken der Natur also Nachschlagewerke eigentlich, die eben über die Örtlichkeit, über den Beschreiber, über das Tier selbst Auskunft geben, aber zusätzlich auch noch die Gene beherbergen, mittels deren wir zusätzlich zu den morphologischen, also den äußeren Merkmalen dann zusätzlich Erkenntnisse zum Beispiel über die Verwandtschaft zwischen den Organismen ziehen können.
Also es sind wirklich sehr sehr wichtige Daten, die wir hier haben in den verschiedenen Sammlungsabteilungen und die wir auch für unsere Arbeit der Biodiversitätsforschung oder auch der biogeographischen Forschung ständig nutzen.
Namensgebend sind dann ja auch nicht selten die Forscher, die dann so das Insekt von der Baumkrone geschabt haben oder in der Tiefsee aufgegabelt haben. Gibt es denn auch schon irgendwas was auf Brand endet?
Oh ja es gibt sehr viel, aber ich kann Ihnen nicht sagen wie viele, weil ich die Arten nie gezählt haben. Aber zum Beispiel haben unlängst zwei meiner Studentinnen einen Flohkrebs in der Antarktis von ungefähr zwei Zentimeter Länge nach mir benannt, Epimiria Angelicae und ja das ist ein Organismus, der wirklich sehr sehr schön aussieht und das ist eine Art, auf die ich tatsächlich auch sehr stolz bin.
Sehr schön. Jetzt muss ich nochmal ein bisschen zurückspulen, weil ich finde das immer sehr interessant, wie man eigentlich zu so einer Tätigkeit gekommen ist. Waren Sie schon immer ein wissenschaftlich interessierter Mensch oder hat Sie das irgendwann mal wie ein Unfall erwischt? Was war so Ihre Reise in dieses Feld?
Zufall. Also ich war schon immer ein wissenschaftlich interessierter Mensch. Ich habe als Kind immer sehr gerne mit Tieren gespielt oder ihnen nachgestellt der sie beobachtet, aber eigentlich wollte ich immer Lehrerin werden. Und habe auch angefangen, Lehramt zu studieren. Habe mein erstes Staatsexamen gemacht, Biologie und Anglistik für Lehramt an Gymnasium. Hatte dann zwischendurch eigentlich auch das Ziel, tatsächlich in die Schule zu gehen. Habe eine Schule gegründet während meiner Studienphase und bin dann aber eigentlich sukzessive – habe auch Diplompädagogik studiert, also ein Doppelstudium angefangen, weil es einfach mein Ziel war, ich werde Lehrerin. Bin ich ja jetzt im Grunde auch für die etwas älteren Kinder, aber es ist eigentlich dann mehr so ganz anders gekommen, weil mich die Faszination eigentlich für die Naturwissenschaften ziemlich gepackt hat. Ich war als Kind schon immer sehr interessiert eben an Organismen. Habe also Filme von Jacques Gusto einfach mit Begeisterung angeschaut. Also im Prinzip das Leben im Meer hat mich schon immer fasziniert.
Und als ich dann in Oldenburg studiert habe, habe ich in einer Arbeitsgruppe gearbeitet, die eben auch an Krebsen gearbeitet haben und habe eigentlich auch während des ersten Semesters gleich so mein Herz an die Athropoden, die Gliedertiere, verloren. Und dann war einfach die Frage, arbeite ich vielleicht später mit Insekten oder mit Krebsen, die einfach morphologisch sehr divers und sehr interessant sind und habe dann einfach aufgrund der wissenschaftlichen Fragestellungen in der Arbeitsgruppe, in der ich gearbeitet habe, und der Tatsache, dass Krebse im Meer, aber Insekten an Land vorkommen und mich das Meer eigentlich mehr fasziniert hat, eigentlich mich mehr oder weniger von der Pädagogik und von der Frage, in die Schule zu gehen, immer mehr in Richtung Naturwissenschaften und damit dann in Richtung Meeresforschung bewegt.
Wie verliert man denn sein Herz an ein Gliedertier?
Indem man sich die äußere Morphologie anschaut. Indem man sich die Diversität der vergleichbaren Objekte anschaut, die es gibt. Also wenn Sie an die Insekten denken, das ist wahrscheinlich das, was man eher kennt und sich die mal im Mikroskop oder im Rasterelektronenmikroskop anschauen, dann haben Sie vielleicht schon mal gesehen, also sind die besetzt natürlich mit unglaublich vielen Sinneshaaren und eigentlich war es das, was mich zu Anfang fasziniert hat, nämlich die Sensorik, diese unglaubliche Vielfalt an unterschiedlichen Möglichkeiten, Sinnenreize aufzunehmen mechanisch und chemisch und damit im Prinzip einen Blick in eine ganz andere Welt der Wahrnehmung und auch des Lebens, was mich einfach fasziniert hat. Die Morphologie, also das was wir von den Tieren sehen, ist so bizarr, so bunt, so unglaublich schön.
Anders auch.
Schön und anders eben, also als Wirbeltiere, dass mich einfach diese Vielfalt, auch diese Heterogenität sehr sehr stark fasziniert hat. Das war eigentlich mit der Hauptgrund muss ich sagen.
Und die Krebse haben Sie dann sozusagen ins Meer entführt?
Die Krebse haben mich dann ins Meer entführt, genau. Oder sagen wir mal so, ich habe mich für die Krebse entschieden, weil sie im Meer leben.
Na gut, ich meine, hier in Hamburg hat man sowieso ganz guten Bezug zum Meer.
Ja ich habe vorher ja in Oldenburg gearbeitet, in Oldenburg in Oldenburg, aber es waren dann eben auch meeresbiologische Exkursionen, die ich als Studentin mitgemacht habe, die einfach dafür gesorgt haben, dass ich dann wirklich mein Herz irgendwann an die Meeresforschung verloren habe und einfach versucht habe, tatsächlich dann in der Meeresforschung auch Fuß zu fassen. Bin dann als Postdoktorandin nach Kiel gegangen an die Universität Kiel. Habe dort in einem Sonderforschungsbereich der deutschen Forschungsgemeinschaft gearbeitet, der sich mit dem Nordatlantik beschäftigt hat, mit Veränderungen der Umwelt und eben den Konsequenzen, die diese Veränderungen auch für die Meeresorganismen haben. Und auf die Art und Weise bin ich dann eben von Kiel aus dann später nach Hamburg gekommen. Habe mich hier auf eine Professur beworben, hatte mich auch in Berlin auf eine Stelle beworben und habe mich dann letztendlich hier für Hamburg entschieden.
Wo man dann aber noch ein bisschen näher dran ist am Meer als in Berlin zum Beispiel.
Das war auch der Grund, warum ich mich für Hamburg entschieden habe. Also ich hatte das Angebot an einem großen Museum, dem Humboldt-Museum oder jetzt Museum für Naturkunde in Berlin und hier in Hamburg zu arbeiten und habe mich dann eben aufgrund der größeren Nähe zum Meer und auch an der größeren Nähe zum Alfred-Wegner-Institut für Polar- und Meeresforschung einfach für den Standort Hamburg interessiert. Weil ich in meiner Doktorarbeitsphase eben in der Antarktis zu Hause war und an dem Ursprung von Krebsen in der Antarktis gearbeitet habe.
Dann war es also die Meeresforschung, die Sie so primär rufen hat. Was heißt das jetzt konkret? Also wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Ich meine, Sie haben natürlich hier ein Büro und einen Standort, aber die Meeresforschung findet ja dann wohl oft auch auf dem Meer statt oder ist das eher die Ausnahme?
Nein das ist natürlich schon so, dass man Material sammelt, Proben nimmt. Wissenschaftliche Fragestellungen versucht zu klären, also Hypothesen aufwirft. Fragen stellt und versucht, dann mittels einer entsprechend methodischen Herangehensweise diese Fragen zu klären. Und die können natürlich vielfältig sein in der Meeresbiologie. Also können vom Kohlenstoffkreislauf über globale Netzwerke, vom Flachwasser bis in die Tiefsee sich erstrecken. Und bei mir ist das einfach so, dass mich die Faszination für die Tiefseeforschung relativ früh gepackt hat, weil während meiner Doktorarbeitsphase, wie ich schon erwähnte, ich an dem Ursprung von Krebsen in der Antarktis gearbeitet habe und dabei eben biogeografische und evolutionsbiologische Analysen gemacht habe und einfach festgestellt habe, dass die Tiefsee um die Antarktis – die Antarktis ist ja im Gegensatz zu den übrigen Kontinenten sehr gut isoliert von Amerika, Afrika und Australien.
Und dass in der Tiefsee um die Antarktis einfach nur schwarze Landkarten existieren mit sehr sehr wenig Daten. Wo man eigentlich gar nicht weiß, was kommt dort vor. Generell in der Tiefsee ist sehr sehr wenig bekannt. Und wenn wir uns unseren Planeten anschauen, jeder kennt das Bild der Erde aus dem Weltall, der blaue Planet Erde. Das bedeutet einfach, 70% unserer Erdoberfläche sind Meer und davon sind nochmal 90% Tiefsee. Das heißt der Durchschnitt der Meere liegt im Abyssal, dem Lebensraum, den wir analysieren. Und das ist auch gleichzeitig der Lebensraum, der eben im Meer am unbekanntesten ist. Die großen Tiefseeebenen, die normalen Tiefseeebenen, wo wirklich relativ wenig an Forschung gemacht wurde.
Sie haben von schwarzen Flecken gesprochen. Traditionell sind es ja die weißen Flecken auf der Landkarte. Heutzutage ist es halt dreidimensional. Sie hatten ja auch schon das andere Extrem genannt, die Baumwipfel. Es gibt halt nicht so viel, wo noch überhaupt kein Mensch gewesen ist. Aber die ganz großen Tiefen gehören ja definitiv dazu. Lässt sich das irgendwie quantifizieren? Ist vielleicht der falsch Ansatz, aber wie muss man sich das vorstellen, wie groß das Unwissen über das Meer vermutlich ist?
Also man kann sicherlich sagen, dass weniger als 1% des Tiefseemeeresbodens überhaupt ist. Also dass man sehr sehr wenig Proben überhaupt hat.
Im Sinne von 1% der Flächen oder der Arten und Höhen?
Der Fläche.
Ja.
Ja maximal 1% der Fläche. Einer meiner Kollegen, John Gage, der auch ein Lehrbuch geschrieben hat über Tiefseebiologie, er lebt nicht mehr, aber er hat die Tiefsee, unsere Kenntnis über die Tiefsee ganz treffend damit verglichen, er hat gesagt, stellen Sie sich einmal vor, alle Landmassen der Erde wären ungefähr so groß wie zwei Fußballfelder. Oder unser Wissen im Verhältnis sozusagen aus der Tiefsee ist wie das Wissen von zwei Fußballfeldern im Verhältnis zu allen Landmassen auf der Erde. Also einfach um so eine Vorstellung zu bekommen, wie wenig es im Prinzip ist, was wir überhaupt an Proben bisher genommen haben.
Das ist wenig.
Das ist wenig. Wir versuchen extraterrestrisches Leben, sage ich jetzt mal, außerhalb unseres Planeten zu analysieren. Uns interessiert, ob der Mars möglicherweise ähnliche Bedingungen wie die Erde für das Leben ermöglichen kann, haben aber unseren eigenen Planeten eigentlich wirklich nur Bruchstücken verstanden.
Ich habe so den Eindruck, das ist fast noch schwerer, da unten runter zu kommen, als auf den Mars.
Also da würde ich jetzt den Kollegen wahrscheinlich aus der Weltraumforschung recht geben und sagen, also der Weg zum Mars ist doch deutlich länger als der Weg zum Tiefseeboden in elf Kilometer Tiefe, aber es ist natürlich auch eine ganz andere Lobby, die Weltraumforschung betreibt, im Gegensatz zu der Lobby, die versucht, Tiefseeforschung zu betreiben. Es ist einfach natürlich sehr spektakulär, einfach so weit von der Erde sich zu entfernen und dort Analysen durchzuführen. Dennoch ist es einfach wichtig, auch Lebensräume auf unserem eigenen Planeten besser verstehen zu können und verstehen zu lernen, denn wir leben auf diesem Planeten mit den anderen Organismen zusammen und sind eines von vielen Lebewesen, von ca. 1,7 Millionen beschriebenen. Und kein Lebewesen der Erde hat die Erde so sehr verändert und beeinflusst und nachhaltig beeinflusst und wir sie auch weiter nachhaltig beeinflussen wie der Mensch.
Die Bedeutung der Meeresforschung hat aber in meiner Wahrnehmung deutlich zugenommen in den letzten Jahren im Rahmen der ganzen Klimafolgendebatte und Forschung. Man hat gemerkt in zunehmendem Maße, welche Rolle die Meere spielen oder zumindest hat man eine Vorstellung davon oder hat zumindest begriffen, dass es eine große Rolle spielt, auch wenn nicht unbedingt klar ist, wie diese Rolle genau aussieht, aber die Erwärmung der Meere, die Fähigkeit der Meere, CO2 aufzunehmen, abzugeben und natürlich auch das komplexe Ökosystem des Meeres mit seinen ganz eigenen Abläufen und Verkettungen und damit eben auch potenziellen Auswirkungen des Klimawandels, scheint mir das Thema doch schon deutlich mehr in den Mittelpunkt gerückt zu haben, als das bisher der Fall war. Ist das die richtige Wahrnehmung?
Ja, aber ich würde es nicht auf die Frage des Klimawandels per sé zurückführen, sondern auch auf generelles Interesse natürlich an der Verbreitung von Organismen. Also der Klimawandel klar ist von Bedeutung im Prinzip auf jedem Niveau. Also von der Atmosphärenforschung bis hin natürlich zur Biodiversitätsforschung und dem Einfluss eben auf die Biodiversitätsforschung. Aber man kann natürlich auch in der Erdgeschichte zurückblicken und sagen, Klimawandel hat es immer gegeben. Es hat bereits fünf große Einbrüche in der Diversität gegeben, Artenextinktionen, angefangen vom Kambrium bis hin zu dieser Hypothese, dass wahrscheinlich der Meteoriteneinschlag im Jura dann dafür gesorgt hat, dass die Dinosaurier ausgestorben sind und sich eigentlich global das Klima eben sehr geändert hat dadurch und eine ganz andere Lebewelt entstanden ist. Aber all diese Fragen haben natürlich auch von Vornherein oder in der früheren Zeit eine große Bedeutung gehabt.
Und ich glaube, dass die Meeresforschung gerade auch was die öffentliche Wahrnehmung angeht in den letzten zehn Jahren durch den sogenannten Zensus of the marine life auch einen großen Aufschwung erfahren hat. Ganz einfach weil eben durch diese vielen Feldprojekte in Verbindung mit einem historischen Projekt, was sich eben mit der Vergangenheit von marinen Tierpopulationen beschäftigt hat und diesem Modellierungsprojekt, was daraus versucht hat abzuleiten eben, aus den ganzen Daten, die diese Feldprojekte gesammelt haben, wie sich möglicherweise die Tierpopulation in der Zukunft entwickeln könnten. Ich glaube dieses Feldprojekt mit dieser enormen Öffentlichkeitsarbeit, also diese große Volkszählung der Meere, der Zensus of the marin life, hat glaube ich die Wissenschaftler auf der einen Seite sehr miteinander vernetzt und neue Möglichkeiten geschaffen, in der Zusammenarbeit, einfach ganz einfach weil das Netzwerk sich noch sehr viel enger gespannt hat in der vergangenen Dekade. Und eben er hat der Öffentlichkeit, der Politik eben auch aufgezeigt, wie zerbrechlich bestimmte Ökosysteme im marinen Bereich sind. Und wie wichtig eben auch die Erforschung dieser Regionen entsprechend ist.
Bleiben wir doch mal kurz bei diesem Zensus. Das ist ja ein riesiges globales Projekt. Wodurch ist das dann entstanden? Also mich erinnert das jetzt so ein bisschen an die Genforschung, wie so dieses, jetzt kartografieren wir mal the Human Genome. Kann man das so in diesem Kontext sehen?
Ja das ist ganz interessant. Also dieses Tiefseeprojekt oder sagen wir dieser Census of marine life wurde eigentlich von einem Tiefseebiologen initiiert. Das war Fred Grassle, Fred Grassle sitzt an der Rutgers-Universität in den Vereinigten Staaten und der hatte halt Kontakt zur Sloan Foundation und hat mit Jesse Ausubel irgendwann darüber gesprochen, dass eben genau dieses Problem, dass die größten Flächen unseres Planeten im Meer sind, dieses auch genau eigentlich die Regionen sind im Meer, die so gut wie unbekannt sind oder wir dort nur relativ wenig Wissen haben. Wir aber, und die Sloan Foundation in den vergangenen Dekaden immer ganz große Forschungsprojekte außerhalb der Biologie finanziert hat, aber irgendwie wir unseren eigenen Planeten gar nicht richtig kennen. Und aus dieser Situation heraus hat sich dann irgendwann diese Idee kristallisiert, mal eine Volkszählung der Meere zu machen.
Und die Idee war, sozusagen mit diesen verschiedenen Feldprojekten, die sukzessive dann auch etabliert wurden, eine große biogeografische Datenbank aufzubauen, die ja auch entstanden ist, sogenannte OBIS, Ocean Bio Geographic Information System. Und in OBIS war von Anfang eigentlich so das Ziel, irgendwo auf den Globus zu klicken und dann sämtliche Namen von Arten, die an dieser Stelle jemals gesammelt worden sind, zu erhalten. Und da sind eben sehr sehr viele Datensätze von verschiedenen Forschern in OBIS eingeflossen und dieses ist eine Datenbank, die obwohl der Zensus of marine life 2010 beendet wurde – also der lief von 2000 bis 2010 – auch heute noch gespeist wird von Wissenschaftlern.
Ich glaube im Rahmen dieses Projektes gab es dann auch einen Zusammenarbeit mit Wikimedia, mit der Wikipedia, mit dem Ziel, dieses Zensus auch sozusagen mehr oder weniger in freies Wissen zu überführen.
Also es gab vor allem ein Projekt Encyclopedia of life, EOL, die sich eben mit verschiedenen, ja die haben Artenblätter entwickelt und haben dann eben basierend auf OBIS versucht, zusätzliche Informationen, Abbildungen und im Prinzip kleine Steckbriefe für diese verschiedenen Arten zu etablieren. Das ist dann aber sehr viel später des Census of marine life erst dazu gekommen.
Kommen wir doch nochmal zu Ihrer konkreten Tätigkeit. Wie gehen Sie das an? Also wie viel Zeit verbringen Sie sozusagen konkret jetzt außerhalb des Büros und sind wirklich in the field, hätte ich jetzt fast gesagt, also auf dem Wasser? Wie viel macht das aus?
Das ist sehr unterschiedlich. Also das kann man schwer quantifizieren. Also ich bin mal nur alle drei Jahre unterwegs. In der letzten Zeit war es sehr häufig. Ganz einfach durch verschiedene Zusammenarbeiten, zu verschiedenen Kooperationen, die wir haben. Also mit russischen Kollegen haben wir seit 2007 oder eigentlich habe ich mit einer russischen Kollegin seit Anfang 2000 zusammen gearbeitet. Wir haben dann 2007 im Rahmen des Zensus of marine life einen internationalen Workshop von der deutschen Forschungsgemeinschaft finanziert in Wladiwostok durchgeführt, um dort mit Kollegen des Institutes uns zu überlegen, ob wir nicht gemeinsame Expeditionen durchführen wollen. Haben dann zunächst einmal ein Memorandum of Understanding formuliert. Haben damit begonnen, Wissenschaftler auszutauschen, uns gegenseitig bei der Ausbildung von Doktoranden zu unterstützen. Und haben dann ein erste gemeinsames Expeditionskonzept entworfen und durchgeführt.
2010 sind wir mit einem russischen Schiff der Academic Lavrentiev ins japanische Meer, also direkt vor die Küste von Wladiwostok gefahren. Haben dort das Tiefseebecken analysiert und haben dann 2012 mit dem alten Forschungsschiff „Sonne“, was jetzt an die Argentinier verkauft wurde, den offenen Kuril im Kamtschatka-Bereich mit russischer Genehmigung bearbeitet. Sind im letzten Jahr 2015 wiederum mit dem russischen Schiff, also wieder auf einer russisch-deutschen Expedition im Ochotskischen Meer gewesen. Haben dort das Kurilenbecken analysiert und werden dieses Jahr im Sommer eben wieder eine deutsch-russische Expedition durchführen mit unserem neuen Forschungsschiff „Sonne“ und direkt im kurilen Kamtschatka-Graben bis in 9500 Meter Tiefe operieren. All diese Projekte haben zum Ziel eigentlich so den biogeografischen Zusammenhang der Fauna zu analysieren.
Und zu analysieren eben auch, haben Tiefseegräben oder Isolationsbarrieren, wie zum Beispiel das japanische Meer ist sehr stark isoliert. Also durch flache Straßen. Das heißt, kann da überhaupt ein Faunenaustausch mit der offenen Tiefseeregion des Pazifiks stattfinden? Also das kann man natürlich nur klären, wenn man auch tatsächlich die Tiefseefauna sich anschaut. Und solche Daten sind wichtig, einfach auch um zu wissen, stellt jetzt so ein Grabensystem zum Beispiel eine Barriere dar, um im Prinzip in der Tiefsee natürlich auch Meeresschutz zu betreiben. Denn es gibt ja im Pazifik, zwar etwas weiter sozusagen im offenen Pazifik, diese sogenannte Manganknollen-Region. Clarion Clipperton Zone, wo auch Deutschland einen Claim hat. Franzosen, Amerikaner, eben verschiedene Länder, die dort im Prinzip sage ich jetzt mal in Lauerstellung darauf warten, tatsächlich auch Manganknollen-Abbau zu betreiben.
Und mann kann natürlich auch nur den Meeresboden schützen und nur schützen was man kennt und insofern ist es schon wichtig zu wissen, wie weit sind eigentlich Organismen verbreitet. Wie groß sind die Flächen, wo bestimmte Arten vorkommen, sind sozusagen meinetwegen 100 oder 1000 Kilometer weiter noch die gleichen Arten zu finden. Das heißt wenn wir dort arbeiten, finden wir dann woanders Arten sozusagen, die dann diese Regionen wieder besiedeln könnten und all diese Informationen kann man natürlich nur erhalten, wenn man überhaupt auch Proben nimmt und den Meeresboden erforscht.
Wie viele Länder betreiben so eine Meeresforschung weltweit? Alle?
Alle sicherlich nicht. Also ich kann Ihnen das jetzt nicht sagen in einer Zahl. Aber alle die, die große Forschungsschiffe betreiben oder im Prinzip in großen Forschungsverbünden mitarbeiten. Also im Prinzip kann jede Nation Tiefseeforschung betreiben. Sie muss sich halt nur entsprechend Kooperationspartner suchen.
Was bedarf es denn für so eine Expedition? Also vielleicht mal kurz auf das Forschungsschiff „Sonne“ zu kommen, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe gibt es zwei. Eins was gerade ausgemustert wird, und eins was danach wieder so heißen wird?
Es gibt zwei, eins was schon so heißt, die neue Sonne ist 2014 in Dienst gestellt worden, die trägt den Namen des alten Schiffes, das ist einfach deutsche Tradition. Wir hatten verschiedene Schiffe, die Valdivia hießen, jetzt verschiedene Meteorversionen. Es wird eine zweite Polarstern geben. Und die alte Sonne ist verkauft worden an das Land Argentinien. Ist umgetauft worden in Austral von den Argentiniern und soll jetzt eben auch für die Forschung direkt am argentinischen Kontinentalhang und in der angrenzenden Tiefsee dann benutzt werden. Ja solche Forschungsexpeditionen werden bei uns in Deutschland von längerer Hand geplant. Also meistens mit Vorlauf von 2-3 Jahren, eher drei Jahre, manchmal können es auch vier sein. Gerade bei solchen Expeditionen, wo Genehmigungen zur Arbeit in internationalen … nationalen Gewässern notwendig sind.
Ist es einfach so, dass Forschungsanträge gestellt werden müssen, um eben in diesen Regionen arbeiten zu können. Also in internationalen Gewässern ist das kein Problem, aber man braucht einfach den Vorlauf, um zunächst einmal überhaupt die Schiffszeit zu bekommen. Also man schreibt einen Antrag, der wird begutachtet. Wenn man dann Schiffszeit hat, muss man eben häufig, kommt darauf an, ob man sich beim Bundesministerium oder bei der deutschen Forschungsgemeinschaft dann bewerben muss, um finanzielle Unterstützung … Muss man einen weiteren Forschungsantrag häufig schreiben und wie gesagt dann dafür sorgen, dass man überhaupt die Forschungsgenehmigung, also die Sammelgenehmigung in den Hoheitsgewässern einer Nation bekommt. Und das braucht einfach mindestens ein halbes Jahr, bis ein Jahr Vorlauf, um diese Genehmigung zu erhalten und die Schiffszeit wird meistens eben auch sehr viel weiter vorher vergeben, weil eben sehr viel Logistik und Planung erfolgen muss, um diese Expedition dann auch zu realisieren.
Wer ist denn der Eigentümer des Schiffs?
Die Bundesregierung.
Das heißt das läuft dann über das Bundesministerium für Bildung und Forschung nehme ich an?
Genau.
In Zusammenarbeit mit den wissenschaftlichen Organisationen. Wie muss man sich so ein Schiff vorstellen?
Ein Schiff.
Was ist da der Unterschied zu einem Fischtrawler oder einem normalen Schiff?
Ja auf einem Forschungsschiff gibt es sehr viel Platz, sehr viele Möglichkeiten. Je nach wissenschaftlicher Fragestellung bringt jede Wissenschaftlergruppe ihre Gerätschaften mit, die sie brauchen. Ob sie jetzt zum Beispiel mit Remotely Operated Vehicles arbeiten, also ROVs einsetzen oder autonome Geräte, dann brauchen Sie sehr viel Platz, sehr viele Container, sehr viel technische Unterstützung, um dann tatsächlich auch diese Geräte fahren zu können. Wir haben häufig eben in Zusammenarbeit mit den russischen Kollegen einfachere Tiefseegeräte eingesetzt, die geschleppt werden hinter dem Fisch. Oder Greifersysteme, die eingesetzt werden, um zum Beispiel einen viertel Quadratmeter Meeresboden an Deck zu holen. Was dann eben später dann analysiert wird.
Das heißt diese Schiffe haben eine feste Besatzung, eine feste Kernbesatzung. Die kennen ihr Schiff, die halten das auf dem Damm, die machen damit sozusagen alle Fahrten, richtige Seeleute.
Ja.
Sind da auch dauerhaft Wissenschaftler an Bord oder ist das sozusagen die variable Komponente? Je nachdem was getan wird.
Das ist genau die variable Komponente in Abhängigkeit von der Bewilligung oder dem Antrag, der gestellt worden ist. Also kann mal Geophysik sein, kann Biologie sein, es kann Ozeanographie sein, also ganz unterschiedlich. Und die maximale Kapazität ist so in der Regel 42/45 Tage, dann muss gebunkert werden, dann muss Sprit erneuert werden auf einem Schiff. Dann wird ein Hafen angelaufen. Häufig auch je nach Fragestellung und Fahrtabschnitt dann früher. Dann wird die wissenschaftliche Mannschaft in der Regel ausgetauscht. Das bedeutet, alles was die eine Gruppe gebraucht hat, die Wissenschaftler, wird wieder zurück gepackt in Kisten, in Container, geht vom Schiff und dann kommen die nächsten Wissenschaftler mit ihren Fragestellungen und entsprechend dann auch nicht nur ihrem wissenschaftlichen KnowHow, sondern entsprechend auch den Geräten, um eben diese Fragestellung dann zu versuchen zu bearbeiten. So dass eben die Mannschaft natürlich auch ausgetauscht wird. Sie können ja nicht auf dem Schiff leben. Sie tun das ein halbes Jahr in der Regel oder fünf Monate.
Haben dann entsprechend auch längere Zeiten wieder Abwesenheit mit der Familie. Also jede Reederei hat in der Regel so zwei große Mannschaften, die sie dann eben im Wechsel immer auf den Schiffen hat. Und entsprechend hat man manchmal eben unterschiedliche Mannschaft eben auch auf den Schiffen, aber vor allem ist es der Stab der Wissenschaftler, der ausgetauscht. Und ein Schiff ist im Prinzip leer. Es gibt natürlich schon jetzt die Bestrebungen, zum Beispiel einige Geräte einfach auf dem Schiff anzuschaffen, direkt von der Regierung, weil sie von vielen wissenschaftlichen Gruppen genutzt werden. Wie zum Beispiel so eine CTD, das ist eine Sonde, mit der man auf der einen Seite Wasserproben, Wasserschöpfer nehmen kann. Gleichzeitig aber auch Daten durch die Wassersäule eben über hydrographische Parameter, wie Temperatur, Salinität, Dichte, Strömungsrichtung erlangen oder erhalten kann.
Und eigentlich braucht ein solches Gerät jede Arbeitsgruppe. Das heißt das bleibt dann auf dem Schiff. Aber so Sonderwünsche wie bestimme Greifersysteme mit Kameras oder Landersysteme brauchen eben manchmal einige wissenschaftliche Fragestellungen oder Wissenschaftler brauchen ein solches System, was eben unabhängig dann von dem Schiff selbst eingesetzt wird, während andere dann Kabel einsetzen, um eben wissenschaftliche Geräte über diese Kabel dann zum Meeresboden zu führen.
Das klingt nach einem ziemlichen Planungsaufwand. Wie viel Vorlauf hat man jetzt für so eine Expedition?
Also wie gesagt, man fängt meistens drei Jahre vorher mit der Planung an, die dann zunächst einmal eben das Antragsschreiben selbst ist.
Das heißt erst muss man sich sozusagen das Schiff sichern?
Genau.
Und davor muss man aber auch im Prinzip schon eine klare wissenschaftliche Mission formulieren?
Die Mission muss klar formuliert sein. Es muss ganz klar formuliert sein auch und berechnet sein, welche Schiffszeit man braucht, wo man die Station nehmen möchte, warum, muss man genau erklären, eben mit der wissenschaftlichen Frage. Und man muss dann eigentlich bis zur Minute ausgerechnet haben auch, wie viel Schiffszeit man mit den Schiffen braucht.
Macht man jetzt aber auch nicht an einem Nachmittag. Also dann würde ich mir ja fast denken, da ist man fast nochmal ein Jahr vorher eigentlich schon mit der Planfassung selbst beschäftigt?
Also man kann so einen Antrag sicherlich über ein Jahr planen, je nachdem wie komplex tatsächlich die Fragestellung ist und wie man die Mannschaft dann auch international zusammenstellen muss. Man kann einen Antrag aber sicherlich auch in kürzerer Zeit schreiben. Also es kommt tatsächlich immer darauf an. Also häufig ist es so, dass sich dann ein Antrag wandelt, in Abhängigkeit sozusagen von der wissenschaftlichen Zusammensetzung. Also wenn jetzt Wissenschaftler auf einmal mit neu dazukommen und sagen, ja aber ich habe hier nochmal eine interessante Fragestellung, dann kann es schon sein, dass es dem Antrag dann auch nochmal eine Wende oder eine leichte Veränderung eben mit auf den Weg gibt, aber hat man dann den Antrag durch, ist dann im Prinzip die Hauptarbeit eher eine logistische Arbeit, tatsächlich dann diese ganzen Genehmigungsverfahren in die Wege zu leiten, mit den entsprechenden Logistikunternehmen zu sprechen, wann Container gepackt werden müssen. Wann die Container verschifft werden. Wie lange die unterwegs sind. Da müssen Gefahrgutdeklarationen gemacht werden.
Also für jedes einzelne Gefahrgut, für jede Chemikalie müssen entsprechend die dangerous goods Formulare ausgefüllt werden, also welche Gefahrklassen das sind, was passieren kann. Die müssen in bestimmten Behältnissen dann transportiert werden. Dann muss natürlich auch überlegt werden, ob man Proben gekühlt für genetische Untersuchungen zum Beispiel oder biochemische Analysen wieder später nach Hause nehmen muss oder schicken lassen muss. Dann muss man mit World-Kurier und Trockeneis eben mit -80 Grad versuchen, dann entsprechend auch das Material wieder so nach Hause zu bringen, damit man eben auch die wissenschaftlichen Fragestellungen tatsächlich weiter bearbeiten kann.
Weil darum geht es ja eigentlich?
Genau.
Was war denn Ihre letzte Expedition mit dem Schiff? War das schon das neue oder war das noch das alte?
Die letzte Expedition war tatsächlich die mit einem britischen Schiff. Ich bin eingeladen worden, eine Expedition in die Antarktis mit durchzuführen mit dem Schiff James Clark Ross. Die letzte Expedition mit der Sonne, auf die wahrscheinlich gerade anspielen, war die mit der neuen Sonne, das war die Jungfernfahrt, die wir gemacht haben. Die Atlantiküberquerung, die wir entlang einer Bruchzone im Atlantik gemacht haben, der sogenannten Clipperton Fracture Zone. Wenn man sich den Atlantik oder die Erde sozusagen vom Weltall aus ansieht, dann sieht man den mittelatlantischen Rücken. Der mittelatlantische Rücken ist im Prinzip durch verschiedene Blattspreizungszonen nochmal unterbrochen. Das heißt, man hat eigentlich erst mal so die Vorstellung, da unten ist ein Gebirge von einer Höhe bis zu 2000 Meter Höhe. Also wenn man sich das so vorstellt, der mittelatlantische Rücken kann große Höhen erreichen, aber er wird eben durchzogen im Prinzip durch Bruchzonen. Also er ist unterbrochen und versetzt, also es ist keine gerade Linie.
Und da ist eben die Frage, welche Bedeutung haben eigentlich solche Strukturen am Meeresboden eben für Organismen in der Verbreitung. Es kommt ja relativ wenig Futter da unten an. Also maximal 5% von dem was oben produziert wird, in der Tiefsee bei 4000 Meter sind das höchstens noch 1% was tatsächlich an Phytoplankton oder organischem Material den Meeresboden noch erreicht. Das heißt die Konkurrenz ist groß oder es müssen eben andere Wege der Nahrungsaufnahme gesucht werden. Wie zum Beispiel viele Organismen essen Aas, wenn irgendwo tote Tiere am Meeresboden verenden, versuchen sie schnell dort hinzuschwimmen oder sind Räuber oder Parasiten, Ektoparasiten, saugen Blut an anderen Tieren zum Beispiel. Da gibt es also vielfältige Möglichkeiten und Mechanismen, die sich entwickelt haben.
Das heißt das Ziel dieser Expedition war primär einfach wieder Bestandsaufnahme? Vor allem erst mal Bestandsaufnahme zu machen, was lebt da eigentlich?
Das war eines der Ziele. Die primäre Frage war, stellt der mittelatlantische Rücken eigentlich eine Isolationsbarriere für die Tiere dar? Finden wir im westlichen und im östlichen Becken des mittelatlantischen Rückens die gleiche Fauna oder gibt es da Unterschiede? Und da haben wir uns vor allem eben versucht Arten anzuschauen, die sich über Larven, also die im freien Wasser dann schweben, und im Prinzip mit der Strömung ja leichter verdriftet werden können, also da haben wir vermutet, dass wir eine weitere Verbreitung haben, also an viel mehr Stationen vorkommen, als zum Beispiel kleine Arten, die Brutpflege betreiben und im Sediment sitzen. Und da gab es eigentlich einige Überraschungen. Es gab natürlich schon die Tendenz, dass die Arten, die Brutpflege betreiben, nicht eine ganz so weite Verbreitung haben, sondern eben an vielen Stationen dann neue Arten vorkommen. Aber es gab durchaus auch eine Art, die an allen Stationen vorkamen, obwohl die Individuen nur Millimetergröße haben und tatsächlich Brutpflege betreiben, eingegraben sind und das ist eigentlich schon spektakulär.
Ich will mich jetzt ein bisschen erst mal noch so auf die Reise machen, um einfach auch mal so ein bisschen diese Dimension dieser Tätigkeit zu sehen. Weil das ist ja jetzt nicht alltäglich. Oft sind ja Wissenschaftler, naja man hat halt auch mal so eine Experimentierphase, da geht man halt ins Labor, schüttet ein wenig Flüssigkeiten von links nach rechts und dann ist auch schon wieder Mittagessen. Hier ist das ja wirklich ganz anders, man investiert ja nicht nur erheblich Zeit in so eine Expedition, man ist ja auch aus allem herausgerissen, also zumindest aus seinem normalen Alltag einfach komplett herausgerissen. Also erst mal noch, wie viele Wissenschaftler waren jetzt, wenn wir mal diese Expedition als Beispiel nehmen, wie viele waren dabei? Wie international war das auch zusammengesetzt? Das war ja sicherlich jetzt nicht nur Wissenschaftler hier aus Hamburg?
Sie meinen jetzt die letzte Expedition mit der Sonne oder die mit den britischen Kollegen? Das waren 13 verschiedene Nationen, die dort an Bord sich getroffen haben. Wir waren etwas mehr als 20 Wissenschaftler, also fast jeder kam tatsächlich auch aus einem anderen Land. Auf Sonne waren wir 40 Wissenschaftler, wir haben die Möglichkeit, 40 Leute mitzunehmen. Und es ist eigentlich wirklich von Fahrtabschnitt zu Fahrtabschnitt und der wissenschaftlichen Frage dann häufig abhängig. Wir hatten früher bei Expeditionen, die wir mit Polarstern gemacht haben, eben auch meistens mehr als Wissenschaftler von zehn Nationen mit dabei. Ganz einfach, weil das einfach besonders wichtig ist, die besten Wissenschaftler halt für bestimmte Arbeitsgebiete dann auch einzukaufen.
Und wenn man dann auf die Expedition sich selbst vorbereitet, was muss man denn da alles, wie lange waren Sie dann weg so im Schnitt?
Also das ist sehr unterschiedlich. Also in der Antarktis ist man schon mal drei Monate unterwegs, ganz einfach weil man schon zehn Tage braucht, um von Kapstadt zum Beispiel die Antarktis zu erreichen. Im Schnitt sind es so sechs Wochen, die man eben mit einem großen Forschungsschiff unterwegs ist, 5-6 Wochen. Ja man muss sich das so vorstellen, dass man im Prinzip wirklich von einem Zellstoffpapier und Gummihandschuhen bis hin zu den Chemikalien, die man braucht, die Behältnisse, die man braucht, bestimmte Plastiktüten, die man braucht, um Organismen zum Beispiel einzufrieren, alles mitnehmen muss. Also die Geräte, jedes Gerät, was man braucht für den Einsatz, weil ja jede Wissenschaftlergruppe andere Fragestellungen verfolgt, ist das Schiff in der Regel leer und all das was man braucht bringt man mit. Das heißt man hat dann zwei oder drei Container entsprechend mit Kisten, mit Expeditionsgut. Das muss vorher gepackt werden, die Zollformalitäten müssen erledigt werden. Je nach Land muss man Visa beantragen oder man braucht eben keine und bekommt ein Touristenvisum dann eben für den Moment, bis man aufs Schiff geht.
Dann fährt man aus dem Hafen aus und fängt im Prinzip sofort an, Container aufzumachen, die Labore einzurichten und alles an den Platz zu bringen, wo man das dann nachher auch haben möchte, wenn man mit den ersten Probenahmen beginnt. Und wenn ich jetzt einfach mal so mit unseren Probenahmen beginne und dann einfach so darüber berichte, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel Greifersysteme einsetzt in 4000 Meter Tiefe, dann hat man ungefähr 4000 Meter Tiefseedraht, die sozusagen zum Meeresboden gehen. Nimmt dann sozusagen eine Tiefseeprobe, holt die an Deck und dann wird im Prinzip wirklich Sedimentschicht für Sedimentschicht, also Zentimeter für Zentimeter analysiert auf die Sedimente, auf den organischen Kohlenstoffgehalt, verschiedene biotische, abiotische Parameter und natürlich dann eben die Organismen. Und je höher im Sediment man sich befindet, desto mehr Organismen sind natürlich auch drin. Das heißt dann im obersten Zentimeter sind eigentlich 98% sage ich jetzt mal der Organismen zu finden.
Setzt man geschleppte Geräte ein, bekommt man in der Regel eine höhere Ausbeute, mehr Biomasse, mehr Organismen, eben auch für verschiedene Fragestellungen der Ökologie oder der Biogeografie zum Beispiel. Das beutetet aber auch, um diese Geräte dann zum Meeresboden zu bekommen und schleppen zu können, muss ich mehr Kabel ausstecken. Das heißt wir fahren in der Regel anderthalbfache Kabellänge zur Wassertiefe. Das heißt wenn ich in 4000 Meter Tiefe operiere, dann muss ich schon 6000 Meter Kabel ausstecken. Und das muss man sich einfach mal vorstellen, dass man dann teilweise so ein kleines Gerät hat, was 2 Meter lang oder 2,50 Meter lang ist, was dann eigentlich 6 Kilometer hinter einem solchen Schiff dann in der Tiefsee hinterhergeschleift wird.
Was ist das denn für ein Kabel? Ich meine 6 Kilometer Kabel das ist ja auch ein ziemlicher Trumm?
Das ist ein 18 Millimeter Kabel, also das hat einen solchen Durchmesser. Da vorne sehen Sie das im Regal liegen, da mit dieser roten Wand ringsum, das ist der Durchschnitt eines solchen Kabels.
Ein dickes Ding ja.
Genau. Und dieses Kabel wiegt pro 1000 Meter ungefähr eine Tonne. Das heißt also bei 2000-3000 Meter Kabel draußen ist das schon schwerer als das Gerät selbst, daher muss man eben auch langsam operieren, damit dieses schwere Kabel das Gerät nicht überholt, das ist einer der typischen und leider häufigen Fehler. Ist uns noch nie passiert Gott sei dank, aber man muss eben wirklich aufpassen. Dann ist das Kabel am Meeresboden, hat das Gerät überholt, das senkt vielleicht noch durch die Wassersäule, man schleppt dann das Kabel und hieft dann wieder, und wenn man Pech hat, ist dann das Gerät gerade unten am Meeresboden erst, wenn das Kabel dann im Prinzip das Gerät wieder hochzieht und man hat eine leere Probe. Und bei einem Forschungsschiff, was 40.000-50.000 Euro am Tag kostet, sind dann 6.000 Euro schon mal schnell 20.000 oder 15.000 Euro, die man verloren hat. Das möchte man natürlich vermeiden.
Ich merke schon, dass Sie eine ganze Menge Erfahrung haben, weil ich wollte gerade noch so ein bisschen mal hinterfragen, wie man sich eigentlich auch so mental darauf vorbereitet, aber Sie stechen irgendwie sofort in See, ohne sich mit solchen Fragen groß Gedanken zu machen. Aber so ein bisschen Aufregung dürfte ja beim ersten Mal schon dabei gewesen sein? Also nicht nur, dass man jetzt so viel falsch gemacht haben kann, sondern das ist doch auch an sich ein ziemliches Erlebnis ist, oder?
Es ist immer so, dass man sehr viel falsch machen kann und für mich ist es auch immer noch so, ein Gerät ist erst mal verloren, in dem Moment wo es das Schiff verlässt. Ich bin immer froh, wenn man das Gerät wieder hat, wenn man dann noch eine Probe in dem Gerät hat, ist es natürlich besonders schön. Bisher ist uns auch eigentlich sehr gut gelungen, sehr erfolgreich Proben von den verschiedenen Expeditionen mit nach Hause zu bringen und entsprechend auch die Daten zu publizieren. Also es sind schon sehr viele wissenschaftliche Publikationen erschienen eben über unsere Arbeit und es ist eben auch so, dass sie nachhaltig auch zur Verfügung stehen. Wir arbeiten ja in einem zoologischen Museum. Das heißt die Daten, die wir erheben, stehen eben auch der Forscherwelt, der Nachwelt zur Verfügung und all das Material, was dann beschrieben wird, zum Beispiel neue Arten, wird dann auch eben in die Eingangskataloge und damit dann eben in die wissenschaftlichen Sammlungen eingearbeitet und steht damit nachhaltig für Biodiversitätsforschung in den nächsten Jahrhunderten zur Verfügung.
Also wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, das Ziel ist natürlich, die Zeit effizient zu nutzen und vor allem natürlich auch die Geräte und Möglichkeiten des Schiffs gut in Position zu bringen. Da hilft einem dann die Mannschaft dabei und natürlich auch das ganze wissenschaftliche Team. Heißt das, dass so im Prinzip der Tagesalltag auf dem Schiff dann darin besteht, im Prinzip so viele Proben rauszuholen wie geht? Das ist sagen wir mal 90% der täglichen Aufgaben?
Das ist für einen Wissenschaftler 100% der Aufgabe. Denn wir arbeiten 24 Stunden Schichten rund um die Uhr. Die Mannschaft besteht in der Regel auch aus zwei Schichten oder der Bootsmann teilt dann entsprechend die Leute ein, so dass halt immer genügend Zeit eben auch bei der Mannschaft da ist, um wieder zu regenerieren, zu schlafen. Bei der Wissenschaft gibt es da unterschiedliche Möglichkeiten und Methoden. Manche sagen, man fährt 12 Stunden Schichten oder fährt 8 Stunden Schichten. Wir machen das bei der Tiefseeforschung in der Regel so, dass wir Geräteverantwortlichkeiten verteilen und sagen, es gibt Wissenschaftler, die arbeiten immer mit dem Argassus-Trawl oder immer mit dem Epibenthosschlitten oder immer mit dem Multicorer, ganz einfach weil dann eben bestimmte Handgriffe, die Probennahme nachher nach einer gewissen Zeit einfach sehr schnell, sehr routiniert und sehr gut abläuft. Die wissen ganz genau, was sie zu tun haben. Vor allem fixieren sie und bearbeiten sie das Material, was sie dann selbst auch wissenschaftlich bearbeiten wollen.
Ich sehe da einfach einen Vorteil drin, im Gegensatz zu diesen 12 Stunden Schichten, wenn man dann auch Material für andere mit bearbeiten muss. Und bei der Tiefseeforschung hat das einfach den Vorteil, es dauert einfach sehr lange, bis ein solches Gerät zum Deck wieder kommt. Also geschleppte Geräte können durchaus 6-8 Stunden unterwegs sein. Und in der Zeit zum Beispiel, wenn ich oder irgendjemand anders dann im Leitstand oder auf der Brücke sitzt, dieses Gerät fährt, können im Prinzip alle anderen schlafen. Also es gibt immer genug Regenerationszeit. Die Regenerationszeit wird eben aber nicht nur zum Schlafen benutzt, muss sie natürlich aber irgendwann, sonst wird es ja gefährlich auf einem Schiff, sondern sie wird natürlich auch für Laborarbeit genutzt. Das heißt es wird schon sortiert, es wird schon extrahiert oder es wird Material für die genetische Untersuchung vorbereitet, entsprechend fixiert und ausgewählt. All diese Arbeitsschritte erfolgen eben auf einem Forschungsschiff und wir versuchen einfach die Zeit so gewinnbringend und so sinnvoll wie möglich zu nutzen.
Denn wir alle wissen, wenn wir später wieder im Büro sind, klingelt das Telefon, wir bekommen E-Mails, die Leute stehen vor der Tür. Also die Zeit, die wir auf dem Schiff sind, ist wirklich reine Wissenschaftszeit und es ist einfach sehr schön, dass wir eine wirkliche sehr sehr gute Forschungsflotte haben in Deutschland. Dass wir sehr gute Möglichkeiten haben und als Wissenschaftler uns dann auf der Expedition auch tatsächlich auf die Wissenschaft konzentrieren können. Wir werden versorgt, wir werden wirklich vorzüglich bekocht auf unseren Forschungsschiffen und müssen uns im Prinzip wirklich um nichts kümmern als um den wissenschaftlichen Output und entsprechend dann das Herangehen an das Material und die wissenschaftliche Probenahme.
Das heißt die mentale Belastung hält sich in Grenzen?
Kommt drauf an. Das kann man so nicht sagen. Also die mentale Belastung kann schon sehr groß werden, wenn man zum Beispiel zwei Wochen Zeit verliert oder aufgrund von Schlechtwetter abwettern muss und im Prinzip nicht genau weiß, wann kann ich überhaupt die Forschung fortsetzen. Das wirkt sich dann besonders natürlich bei jungen Wissenschaftlern aus, die Master- oder Bachelorstudenten, also früher Diplomstudenten oder Doktoranden, die im Prinzip dann wirklich davon abhängig sind, auf einer 6-Wochen-Expedition wirklich gutes Probenmaterial mit nach Hause zu nehmen. Da ist es dann schon manchmal so, dass man die wissenschaftlichen Fragestellungen abwandeln muss. Also das kann dann schon natürlich zu mentalem Stress führen auf solchen Expeditionen. Es ist teilweise auch natürlich sehr anstrengend, 24 Stunden Schichten zu fahren. Wie wir sie fahren, kann es schon mal sein, dass man mal nachts arbeitet, dann arbeitet man tagsüber. Das heißt also, es ist ein unregelmäßiger Rhythmus, den man dann teilweise hat. Und es ist eben auch sehr sehr viel Arbeit. Also es ist eigentlich kein Wochenende, kein Feierabend.
Man kommt dann nach 6 Wochen vom Schiff, hat keinen Samstag gehabt, hat keinen Sonntag gehabt, hat keinen Tag frei gehabt und die Kollegen sagen, und war es schön auf der Expedition? Sie sind ja schön braun geworden, weil man dann vielleicht bei 10 Grad Nord 26 Grad draußen an Deck gestanden hat und gearbeitet hat. Aber man sieht dann einfach gut erholt aus.
Setzt man sich da nicht mal zumindest 5 Minuten auf einen Sessel und schaut sich mal … weiß nicht, an Landschaften kommt man wahrscheinlich gar nicht so viel vorbei, aber?
Natürlich macht man das auch.
Klingt man sich mal so aus.
Das geht ja gar nicht anders. Also ich meine, wir sind ja alle Menschen. Also ich meine, wenn man auf …
Das muss ja auch ein fantastischer Sternenhimmel sein da draußen oder?
Ja ist es, sicherlich. Und ich meine, es gibt natürlich immer solche Momente, wo man im Prinzip zum Beispiel darauf wartet, das Gerät kommt jetzt hoch, es hat noch 1000 Meter und irgendjemand brüllt, Buckelwal vor Achtern. Und dann laufen erst mal alle und holen schnell ihre Kamera und gucken nach dem Buckelwal. Oder es sind jetzt in der Antarktis Albatrosse, die ums Schiff kreisen und das ist einfach wunderschön, dann diese Tierwelt zu beobachten. Oder es sind Pinguine, die irgendwo auf Eisschollen sich ausruhen oder auch Robben, wenn man durch Eisfelder fährt. Wir hatten jetzt zum Beispiel bei dieser Antarktis-Expedition einfach durch Zufall das Glück, an einem Eisfeld vorbeizufahren, das sich eben vom östlichen Wedell-Meer nach Norden erstreckt hat. Ein riesengroßer Eisberg ist zerfallen und dort wo Eis ist ist auch Krill, weil der Krill sich eben von den Untereisalgen ernährt und wo Krill ist sind auch Wale. So dass wir da einfach mit dem Schiff eben auf dem Weg zu unserem Probenahmengebiet durch eine Region gefahren sind, wo unheimlich viele Wale waren und auf einmal war rechts und links überall Walblas und natürlich lässt jeder in dem Moment dann alles stehen und liegen und geht erst mal eine halbe Stunde raus. Das muss dann einfach auch sein.
Das ist dann die Entlohnung sozusagen für die Arbeit und für den Mangel an Freizeit und Wochenenden.
Sie haben es schon ein paar Mal angedeutet, aber mich interessiert es auch nochmal, wie man sich sozusagen die Technik dort vorstellen muss. Also ich habe jetzt schon mitbekommen, es gibt mindestens drei unterschiedliche Arten und Weisen, Proben zu nehmen, vielleicht sind das noch nicht mal alle Methoden. Sind sie oder sind sie nicht?
Sind nicht alle Methoden, nein. Also ganz grob charakterisiert kann man sagen, also man kann autonome Systeme fahren, mit denen man zum Beispiel am Meeresboden Fotos machen kann.
Also so ein fernsteuerbares U-Boot?
Ja genau. Oder die man halt vorher programmiert. Also in der Ozeanographie haben ja in den letzten Jahren so Floats und Gliders, also im Prinzip Computer, die man sozusagen ins Meer einsetzt und die dann Daten sammeln und an Satelliten die Daten sozusagen übermitteln. Das hat also wirklich die Ozeanographie revolutioniert, solche Methoden. Und es ist klar, dass so was in der Tiefsee einfach fehlt. Das ist auch eines der Ziele eigentlich würde ich sagen der Tiefseeforschung für die nächsten Dekaden. Wir haben jetzt so gute Forschungsschiffe. Unsere Forschungsflotte wird in Deutschland und auch in vielen anderen Ländern erneuert. Wir haben teilweise aber eben immer noch Geräte, die eingesetzt werden, die erinnern noch an die Kinderstube der Tiefseeforschung, also Geräte zum Beispiel hinter dem Schiff her zu schleppen. Sind zwar verbesserte Methoden, verbesserte Geräte, feinmaschigere Geräte, die bessere Proben und umfangreichere Proben zutage bringen, dennoch dauert das immer noch sehr lange, und solche Schiffszeittage kosten natürlich auch sehr viel Geld.
Und da kann man sicherlich mit der heutigen Technik, die im Prinzip zur Verfügung steht, sehr viel mehr machen.
Also es dauert lange, weil man so aufwändig die Kabel ausrollen muss und sehr vorsichtig sein muss.
Genau, in der Zeit kann man kein anderes Gerät fahren. Das heißt eine solche Probennahme kann von 8-12 Stunden dauern, wenn wir jetzt im Hadal operieren, also in mehreren tausend Meter Tiefe, also mehr als 6.000 Meter Tiefe, dann muss ich im Prinzip 9.000 Meter Kabel ausstecken, bei 8.000 Meter sind es schon 12.000 Meter Kabel. Also die maximale Nutzlänge sind 11.000 Meter und da bin ich dann wirklich bei einer Probenahme bei 8-9 Stunden. Also es gibt einfach von den technischen Möglichkeiten vielleicht doch auch die Möglichkeit, Unterwasserroboter zu bauen, die einfach auch autonom Proben nehmen. Das Problem bei den momentan bestehenden oder genutzten Systemen, wie ROVs ist, dass die Probenmenge noch teilweise zu klein ist für Fragestellungen der Evolutionsbiologie oder der Ökologie, wo man einfach mehr Material braucht. Und da muss eigentlich jetzt auch die Entwicklung hingehen, autonome Sammelgeräte zu entwickeln für die Zukunft, die unsere Forschungsschiffe einfach von der Zeit her, von dem zeitlichen Einsatz ein bisschen entlasten.
Aber gleichzeitig eben auch der Ökologie, der Evolutionsbiologie, der Biodiversitätsforschung die Möglichkeit geben, mehr an Proben zu nehmen und gleichzeitig eben automatisiert zum Beispiel Fotos während der gleichen Zeit zu machen, so dass man eine Vorstellung über die Biomasse der großen Organismen pro Flächeneinheit bekommt. Dann gibt es die Möglichkeit, auch schon genetische Marker im Prinzip zu nehmen. Aber solche Geräte, die all das sozusagen zusammengesetzt können, gibt es noch nicht. Die entwickelt worden sind bisher, in der Tiefsee dort Einsatz zu finden.
Das heißt eigentlich, man bräuchte so einen universal-Tauchroboter, der alles mit Ultraschall abscannen kann oder mit Laser, mit ??? oder anderen Techniken?
Also es gibt da verschiedene, natürlich je nach Fragestellung, verschiedene Anwendungsmöglichkeiten und verschiedene Probenahmeziele, sage ich jetzt mal. Also das kann zum Beispiel im Prinzip wie so ein Staubsauger ein Gerät sein, was bestimmte definierte Probemengen sammelt und dann irgendwo abliefert und dann irgendwann mit einem Fahrstuhl oder so zum Deck bringt, zum Beispiel zu einem Schiff. Dann kommt ein Schiff vorbei, das kann dann, was weiß ich, die 15 Proben, die in der Vergangenheit gesammelt worden sind, dann von diesem Gerät wieder einsammeln. All das wäre technisch möglich.
Das heißt Sie sprechen sogar auch schon von Geräten, die eigentlich unabhängig von einem bestimmten Forschungsschiff sind, sondern die einfach irgendwo operieren und wer als nächstes vorbeikommt nimmt das einfach mit, so ein bisschen wie ein Postbote.
Genau. Das gibt es ja für, ich sagte in der Weltraumtechnik, Robotnik, also Geräte, die tatsächlich da über den Mars fahren, Proben nehmen und dann auch wieder irgendwohin zurückfahren. Und wenn das möglich ist, muss das auch am Tiefseeboden möglich sein. Die Möglichkeiten bestehen im Prinzip in Einzelmodulen, aber es ist eben noch nichts gebaut oder geplant, was eben da die deutsche Tiefseeforschung in Bezug auf größere Mengen an Organismen entlasten würde. Aber es gibt die Möglichkeiten. Also das deutsche Zentrum für künstliche Intelligenz, DFKI, hat drei Standorte in Deutschland. Ein Standort ist in Bremen. Und die haben in Bremen auch ein ganz großes Tauchbecken, wo sie im Prinzip also Geräte, die sie entwickeln, dann eben auch direkt einsetzen können.
Autonome Geräte genau. Und dort testen können. Das heißt natürlich nicht unter Druck. Also dieses riesige Becken kann da nicht abgedrückt werden, sage ich jetzt mal, auf 300 Bar, so dass man 3.000 Meter Tiefe simulieren kann, aber zumindest ist es ein guter Anfang, um mal überhaupt die Funktionalität dieser Geräte, die entwickelt werden, zu testen. Und da denke ich wird in der Zukunft auch die Tiefseeforschung deutlich voranschreiten müssen.
Also autonome Geräte da bauen.
Ja der Vergleich mit der Raumfahrt und dem Mars, der ist immer schnell gesagt, aber eigentlich müsste man es ja mit der Venus-Forschung vergleichen, so wie die Druckverhältnisse unter Wasser sich da eben präsentieren. Und auch da hat ja die Raumfahrt so ihre Schwierigkeiten, überhaupt erst mal was auch nur auf den Boden zu bekommen. Wie groß ist denn noch die technische Herausforderung? Also ist sozusagen das Problem des Herablassens von Technik in diese ultratiefen Bereiche, - ich weiß gar nicht, was ist der tiefste Punkte des Ozeans, den wir kennen?
11.300 Meter, der Marianengraben.
Das ist ja schon eine unwirtliche Gegend, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf. Also für unsereins auf jeden Fall.
Ja also ich meine Herausforderungen sind natürlich einmal die Kapazität an Energie, Powersupply???, also autonome Geräte, die jetzt eben ohne Draht gefahren werden, müssen entsprechend dann bei Kälte, unter starkem Druck eben teilweise sehr sehr lange arbeiten können. Es gibt schon solche Systeme, die im Prinzip so etwas wie so eine Dockingstation haben, Crawlersysteme???, so kleine Unterwasserfahrzeuge. Die fahren dann los, können im Prinzip Proben nehmen. Sind auch für andere Zwecke im Prinzip eher für Biogeochemie oder Fragestellungen des Abscannens des Meeresbodens, aber noch nicht der Probenahme entwickelt. Könnten dann zurückfahren im Prinzip zu dieser Dockingstation, sich dort wieder aufladen. Irgendwann muss die Dockingstation natürlich auch aufgeladen werden oder sie wird eben sozusagen dann über Powersupply von oben dann von einer Plattform aus zum Beispiel betrieben.
Aber im Prinzip so weit sind wir noch nicht. Aber diese Möglichkeiten, im Prinzip über eine Plattform die Energie wiederum zu ziehen, bestehen bereits. Wenn man jetzt solche Systeme hat, die dann tatsächlich auch Proben nach oben bringen müssen, ist das Problem einfach sozusagen diese Sedimentmengen loszuwerden und im Prinzip vor Ort im Wasser schon zu versuchen, ein Teil der Sedimentfracht wegzuwerfen, aber die Proben eben zu haben, die Tiere zu haben. Und das ist eigentlich eine Herausforderung. Weil man dieses Gewicht natürlich, diese Tonnen an Schlick natürlich nicht nach oben befördern kann.
Also die Spreu vom Weizen trennen sozusagen?
Genau.
Das heißt in gewisser Hinsicht eine intelligente Analyse. So ein bisschen wie der Blick des Mondfahrers, welches Steinchen nehme ich denn jetzt auch tatsächlich wieder zurück zur Erde. Das ist sozusagen die entscheidende Leistung.
Dann trotzdem quantifizierter zu machen. Dass man jetzt nicht irgendwie sagt, ich will da jetzt nur so ein paar haben, dann kann man keine Prozesse analysieren, dann sieht man nur Muster und sieht, aha war jetzt gerade da dieses Tier, aber warum? Und wie ist die Biomasse und in welcher Fläche haben wir das jetzt gefunden und wie sehen da noch die abiotischen Parameter und Rahmenparameter aus? All diese Informationen will man ja auch haben. Und da ist es dann schon schwieriger, weil man dann einfach versucht natürlich, mit verschiedenen Methoden ein Gerät tatsächlich so auszustatten, dass es eben multifunktionell ist und je mehr es können soll desto schwieriger ist es natürlich, weil man immer wieder auf neue Probleme trifft.
Gibt es denn in solchen Tiefen auch noch starke Strömungen?
Teilweise ja. Also in Canyons zum Beispiel, am Fuße von Kontinentalhängen können die Strömungen teilweise sehr sehr stark sein. Es kommt immer auf die Topografie auch des Meeresbodens an. Wenn Sie über lange homogene Fläche, im Prinzip sage ich jetzt mal, Tiefseemeeresboden haben, ist die Chance einer sehr starken Strömung nicht so groß. Es sei denn, es ist irgendwo ein Tsunami ausgelöst worden zum Beispiel oder es hat eine Rutschung gegeben, dann hat man natürlich schon Druckwellen, die sich dann auch über viele tausend Kilometer fortsetzen können. Aber im Prinzip ist natürlich die Strömungsgeschwindigkeit dort eben sehr stark, wo Sie im Prinzip Canyons haben, also so Kanalsysteme, die dann die Strömungsgeschwindigkeit verschnellert.
Das heißt eigentlich ein intelligent autonom agierendes Gerät/Wissenschaftsgerät müsse im Prinzip auch noch mit der Strömung klarkommen? Aber wenn ich mir das jetzt so vorstelle, wäre so das Ideal, man hätte oben so eine klare Solarinsel, wo dann so eine lange Steckdose mit Rohrpostsystemen quasi einen 11 Kilometer langen Schlauch nach unten lässt, wo dann unten quasi so eine Steckdose für ein autonom agierendes Gerät ist, was dann regelmäßig sich so die richtigen Proben raussucht, aber das bevor sozusagen die Guten ins Köpfchen packt, das quasi entsprechend auch noch kartografiert, aber dann eben so die eigentliche Essenz in eine kleine Kapsel packt und die wieder nach oben schießt. Das wäre so ein bisschen der Traum?
Das wäre der Traum, die Umsetzung würde ich dann den Ingenieuren überlassen, aber das wäre im Prinzip nicht nur der Traum, sondern ich glaube, das ist wirklich für die Tiefseeforschung in der zukünftigen Generation einfach notwendig, dass wir da einfach vorankommen. Denn die Möglichkeiten, die man eben hat, über Satelliten heute, Daten auszuwerten, die muss man versuchen, sich eben auch für die Tiefseeforschung zunutze zu machen und da eben auch versuchen, die Forschungsentwicklung und Geräteentwicklung in diese Richtung voranzutreiben.
Inwiefern ist denn die Raumfahrt der Meeresforschung entgegengekommen? Es gibt ja nun auch zahlreiche Beobachtungssysteme, die sich die Meere auch nochmal genauer angeschaut haben, wo auch Strömungen, Temperaturen und ähnliche Informationen gewonnen werden, haben Sie da Berührungspunkte? Welchen Beitrag hat die Raumfahrt für die Meeresforschung?
Ich glaube einfach, dass im technischen Bereich da sehr viele Parallelen gezogen werden und eben Geräte, wie ich schon sagte, also solche Crawlet-Systeme zum Beispiel, die entwickelt worden sind, dann tatsächlich jetzt auch versucht werden, jetzt auch für Fragestellungen und Anwendungen eben in der Tiefsee nutzbar zu machen und entsprechend abzuwandeln. Ich glaube das ist einer der Hauptgesichtspunkte, eben sozusagen der technische Fortschritt für die Raumfahrt, der eben in der Umsetzung jetzt versucht wird, auch für die Tiefseeforschung nutzbar gemacht zu werden.
Aber die konkrete Beobachtung aus dem All spielt für Ihre Arbeit erst mal so keine Rolle?
Für die Tiefseeforschung ist es noch sehr schwer. Für Oberflächenforschung natürlich schon, also Primärproduktion, da kann vom All aus natürlich sehr viel gemacht werden, insofern als dass man zumindest natürlich Farbveränderungen wahrnehmen kann und damit natürlich auch sofort erst mal sieht, wo sind Regionen eben sehr starker Primärproduktion, aber für die Tiefseeforschung, also für den Meeresboden, dazu ist die Wassersäule einfach, die darüber liegt, zu groß und zu sedimentgeladen, so dass man eben eigentlich die Prozesse am Meeresboden so noch nicht analysieren kann.
Jetzt ist es ja so, der Blick in die Tiefsee, wann ist es denn der Menschheit und die Wissenschaftlern gelungen, überhaupt relevante Tiefen zu erreichen, so dass man von Tiefseeforschung wirklich sprechen kann? Und worauf ist man dann gestoßen? Was unterscheidet die tiefe See von dem marinen Leben, wie man es so gemeinhin kennt oder meint zu kennen?
So lange ist das noch gar nicht her eigentlich, dass wir intensive Tiefseeforschung betreiben. Also unter Colin Forbes???, der im 19. Jahrhundert gearbeitet hat, der britischer Malakologe, also Weichtierforscher und hat eben auch an der biogeografischen Forschung sehr stark mitgearbeitet. Der hat halt die Abyssus-Theorie aufgestellt. Und hat anhand von Proben, die er von Seesternen vorliegen hatte, halt festgestellt, dass die Anzahl der Seesterne mit zunehmender Tiefe immer mehr abnimmt und hat bei 400 Meter Tiefe noch einen Seestern gefunden und hat gesagt, da ist wahrscheinlich dann die Grenze, ab 500 Meter Tiefe ist das Leben im Meer azoisch???, da gibt es nichts mehr. Und wir alle wissen, dass die ersten Tiefseeexpedition der Challenger dann Ende des 19. Jahrhunderts die Wissenschaft da aufgeklärt haben, dass das ganz anders aussieht.
Dass sehr sehr viele Tiere am Meeresboden leben, Organismen eigentlich von Schwämmen bis hin zu Stachelhäutern, die man auch in Flachwasserregionen kennt. Und das war eigentlich revolutionär, weil man einfach überhaupt gar nicht davon ausgegangen ist, dass da unten überhaupt noch Leben existiert. Und wenn man sich das vorstellt ist das natürlich auch so wie ich schon eingangs versucht habe zu verdeutlichen, alles Leben im Meer hängt natürlich ab letztendlich von der Primärproduktion, also Nährsalzen und Sonnenenergie, die eben Phytoplankta bilden und das ist letztendlich die Grundlage allen Lebens und man hat eigentlich nur in der lichtdurchfluteten Zone überhaupt die Möglichkeit oder Organismen und Algen bilden oder unter dem Eis Eisalgen, so dass eigentlich das ganze Leben im Meer indirekt eigentlich durch diese Primärproduktion gespeist wird. Und man sagt eigentlich immer so als generelle Definition, ab 200 Meter Tiefe, da haben wir dann den kontinentalen Schelf, da geht es dann in den kontinentalen Hang über, beginnt dann im Prinzip schon so die Zone der Dunkelheit.
Ab 1000 Meter ist es dann komplett dunkel und in diesen Zonen ist es so, dass das Leben eben immer geringer wird. Und das ist eigentlich das Faszinierende, dass wir eben im Prinzip in Regionen, die unterhalb von 200 Meter liegen, teilweise sehr geringe Kenntnisse haben. War sehr spektakulär eigentlich, weil der Zensus of Marine Life zu Anfang aufgezeigt hat, dass über 90% unseres Wissens aus den obersten 50 Metern der Wassertiefe tatsächlich herrühren. Planktonproben, die genommen worden sind. Sobald wir unter 100 Meter Tiefe sind, wir nur noch sozusagen 1% des Wissens haben und unterhalb von 1000 Meter nur noch 0,09%, also wirklich extrem geringe Kenntnisse, als der Zensus of Marine Life begonnen hat. Also mit zunehmender Tiefe wissen wir einfach relativ wenig.
Aber man hat ja dann doch mit der Zeit einiges entdeckt und es tat sich eine skurrile Lebenswelt auf. Selbstleuchtende Fische, transparente Fische, überhaupt auch Wesen, wo so unsere klassische Vorstellung des Begriffs Fisch auch irgendwie ein wenig ausgesetzt hat. Wann war das, dass man auf diese Wesen gestoßen ist und wo befinden die sich eigentlich, also in welchen Tiefen?
Also die befinden sich vor allem in der Dunkelzone. Ich kann Ihnen jetzt keine Jahreszahl nennen, wann also Biolumineszenz tatsächlich entdeckt worden ist, ganz einfach weil das jetzt nicht mein Arbeitsbereich ist, aber es ist einfach in der Evolution, also in der Entwicklungsgeschichte der Organismen im Meer, an Land, dass natürlich irgendwo mit jeder Eroberung eines neuen Lebensraumes dann teilweise auch Neuerungen einhergehen. Und Biolumineszenz wird von Organismen eben in vielerlei Hinsicht benutzt. Das typische Beispiel, was jeder am ehesten noch kennt, sind Anglerfische. Wo dann zum Beispiel in bestimmten Strukturen, also in der sogenannten Angel im Prinzip, einen verlängerten Flossenstrahl zum Beispiel ein Paket an Photobakterien hängt, die eingeschaltet werden können, wo dann aufgrund eines oxidativen Prozesses Luciferin, also über Luciferase da oxidiert wird, und dann zum Leuchten gebracht wird. Diese Bakterien, die dann kurzzeitige Lichtblitze aussenden, locken dann Organismen an.
Häufig haben die Tiefseeorganismen noch rudimentäre Augen, können noch Lichtblitze wahrnehmen, weil sie sich ganz einfach an der Evolution abgeleitet haben von verwandten Organismen, die zum Beispiel auf den kontinentalen Schelfen vorkommen, dort Jäger sind oder überhaupt ihr Futter finden müssen, gute Augen haben, gute Nasen oder chemische Sinnesorgane haben und können also praktisch noch Lichtblitze sehen und die werden dann angezogen von dem Licht und schon hat der Fisch ein mögliches Beutetier im Prinzip vor seiner Angel und kann es fressen. Das hat einen Vorteil verschafft, dadurch haben dann vielleicht die Nachkommen auch wiederum im Prinzip einen Vorteil gehabt, so dass eben über diese Selektion dann sich sukzessive in der Evolution diese Besonderheit entwickelt hat. Andere haben zum Beispiel geben Biolumineszenz, diese Photobakterien ab und produzieren dadurch eine Wolke, fliehen dann. Also ist ein ganz anderer Prozess im Prinzip, wo zum Beispiel von Ruderfußkrebsen, kleinen Krebsen, dieser Mechanismus genutzt wird zur Flucht, um eben potenziellen Fressfeinden zu entgehen.
Ja so ein bisschen das Äquivalent zu der Tinte des Tintenfisches?
Genau, also im Prinzip eigentlich ein sehr ähnliches Phänomen.
Also es gibt kein Licht, es herrschen extreme hohe Drücke in dieser Zone. Was ist denn sonst noch in unseren Augen lebensfeindlich, was sozusagen allein die Präsenz dieser Organismen schon so skurril macht?
Das ist Nahrungsarmut eben auch. Also Nahrungsarmut, hoher Druck und Dunkelheit im Prinzip, die natürlich mit der Nahrungsarmut dann auch korreliert. Das sind eigentlich so die Hausbedingungen, die für uns zunächst einmal unwirtlich erscheinen, aber man muss sich einfach darüber im Klaren sein, dass viele der Organismen, die wir dort vorfinden, seit Millionen von Jahren in der Tiefsee leben und das für die eigentlich eher eine Normalität ist. Also man geht immer so mit dem anthropozentrischen Blickwinkel natürlich an die Erklärungsmuster heran und versucht unsere Welt zu erklären, aber man muss sich auch einfach mal vorstellen, wie Organismen zum Beispiel in der Antarktis leben. Da sagt man immer, das ist ein extremer Lebensraum. Ja ist er vielleicht, wenn man das vergleicht mit den tropischen Regionen, aber ein antarktischer Eisfisch der kommt in den tropischen Regionen richtig in Stress, weil er ganz einfach natürlich von seiner Physiologie über 20 Millionen Jahre an die kalten Klimate angepasst ist und dort wunderbar leben kann und für ihn dieser Lebensraum überhaupt gar keinen Stress beinhaltet. Also man muss da immer sehr vorsichtig sein.
Das heißt es gibt auch überall Leben? Auch in 11 Kilometer Tiefe?
Ja, das haben damals schon Piccard und Don Walsh mit der Tauchkugel Triest festgestellt. Die sind ja die ersten Wissenschaftler gewesen, die in den Marianengraben getaucht sind und wirklich in mehr als 11.000 Meter Tiefe berichtet haben, dass sie dort Plattfische gesehen haben. Ob es tatsächlich Plattfische waren oder ob es sich, wie ich vermute, um flache Holothurienarten, also es gibt da eine Gruppe von Seegurken, die also sehr sehr flach aussehen, relativ große Größen erreichen können und die man wenn sie mit Sediment bedeckt sind eben sicherlich auch sehr leicht für Plattfische halten kann. Aber es wurden eben damals Lebewesen sowohl in der Wassersäule gesehen als auch am Meeresboden gefunden und insofern sind das natürlich fantastische Entdeckungen gewesen.
Was ist denn jetzt nach, wie lange betreiben Sie das Feld jetzt schon Meeresforschung? Wie lange sind Sie da jetzt dabei?
Also mit der Antarktisforschung habe ich eigentlich zu Beginn meiner Doktorarbeit Ende der 80er Jahre begonnen. Also man kann sagen, dass ich 30-35 Jahren eigentlich Meeresforschung betreibe.
Was ist denn die Bestandsaufnahme unserer Meere? Man hört ja viel schlechtes. Es ist alles vermüllt. Es leidet unter dem Schiffsverkehr, in Form von Verschmutzung, in Form von Lärm, vielleicht auch noch in anderen Formen, weiß ich nicht. Ist denn Alarmismus hier angesagt oder ist eigentlich alles supi? Wie muss man sich den Zustand unserer Meere heute vorstellen?
Also ich denke, es ist schon Alarm angesagt. Also man sollte die Verschmutzung unseres Planeten nicht auf die leichte Schulter nehmen. Es ist bekannt, dass im Pazifik es Regionen gibt, The Great Garbage Road, wo einfach im zentralen Pazifik aufgrund von Strömungsmustern tatsächlich große Flächen im Prinzip der Meeresoberfläche von Plastikmüll bedeckt sind. Wo man mit dem Schiff dann hindurchfahren kann und dieser Plastikmüll dann dort zu sehen ist. Der begibt sich auf Reise natürlich auch rund um den Globus. Also faszinierend war für viele dieses Beispiel des umgekippten Containers mit den gelben Quietscheentchen, die sich also im Laufe sozusagen der Jahre jetzt über den ganzen Pazifik ausgebreitet haben, wohl im arktischen Ozean angekommen sind. Das ist eine sehr schöne Ausstellung, die im deutschen Meeresmuseum in Stralsund im Katharinenkloster, also in dem Hauptmuseum zu sehen ist.
Also im Prinzip der Gang des Plastikmülls oder die Verbreitung des Plastikmülls über die Meere. Wir haben einfach bei unseren Expeditionen im kurilen Kamtschatka-Graben an den tiefsten Stationen in 5.800 Meter Tiefe, die wir bisher beprobt haben, auch schon sehr sehr viel Plastikmüll in den Proben gehabt. Wir hatten zwei Stationen, wo unser Epibenthosschlitten, der also 2,5 Meter Länge aufweist, tatsächlich komplett von Planktonnetzen und Treibnetzen mit sehr sehr vielen Haken aus der Fischerei umgeben war. Also im Prinzip eingepackt wie ein Bonbon in Treibmüll, in Netzen, Fischereinetzen. Also das ist schon sehr bedenklich. Denn wenn der Müll erst mal die Gräbensysteme erreicht hat, dann wird er dort bleiben. Also er wird aus den Gräbensystemen nicht mehr in andere Regionen wieder abtransportiert werden können.
Und man kriegt ihn da auch nicht weg?
Man kriegt ihn da auch nicht. Das heißt also der Mensch müllt schon auf diese Art und Weise den Ozean ordentlich zu. Auf der anderen Seite hat man natürlich schon auch festgestellt, Wracks, Holzgegenstände, eigentlich alle Oberflächen werden sukzessive auch von Heeresorganismen dann irgendwann besiedelt, aber es ist eben eine Frage der Zeit, bis überhaupt eine Besiedlung stattfinden kann und beim Plastikmüll ist es eben häufig so, dass gerade Plastiktüten, wenn sie sich dann über Organismen darüberlegen, einfach natürlich das Leben darunter zerstören, ganz einfach weil dann keine Atmung oder keine Nahrungsaufnahme mehr möglich ist, keine Atmung mehr möglich ist für die Organismen, und es dadurch dann natürlich auch zum Absterben von vielen Organismen führt, bevor dann entweder das Plastik irgendwann abgebaut ist oder eben möglicherweise bei härterem Material als Plastiktüten dann ein sekundäres Substrat dort aufgebaut werden kann von den Organismen selbst.
Das heißt, dass diese Plastiktüten selber dann wiederum von Bakterien zerfressen werden?
Ja das ist sozusagen die Zeit, im Prinzip das dauert wirklich hunderte von Jahren, bis dann Plastiktüten wirklich verschwinden oder irgendwann abgebaut sind und dann in Form von Mikroplastik sich zum Beispiel erst mal im Sediment wiederfinden. Was wir eben auch sehen, dass teilweise bei unseren Proben in 4.000-5.000 Meter Tiefe haben, wenn wir nach den Tiefen suchen, immer wieder auch kleine Fragmente an Plastikmüll praktisch in unseren Proben drin. Aber andere können natürlich auch besiedelt werden. Wie Turnschuhe zum Beispiel. Da sind dann teilweise also die Sohlen aufgearbeitet, da sitzen dann auch schon mal Schnecken drauf, oder Organismen, Moostierchen, die sich dort angesiedelt haben können, die dann im Prinzip dieses vermeintliche Hartsubstrat, weil es in der Tiefsee ja nicht so viel davon gibt, einfach nutzen, um dann dort einen Lebensraum dann wieder neu zu erschließen.
Aber es muss doch schon so ein bisschen frustrierend sein. Ich stelle mir gerade mal vor, wir schicken jetzt wirklich mal einen Menschen auf den Mars und der öffnet da irgendeine kleine Höhle und findet da halt einen Turnschuh, so ist es doch irgendwie wenn in 11 Kilometer Tiefe einen noch nicht erforschten Bereich sich anschaut und feststellt, die Menschheit war schon irgendwie da, nur nicht unbedingt jetzt so wie wir das jetzt gerade machen?
Das ist schon sehr beängstigend. Also man sieht schon die Bedrohung des Menschen, die Bedrohung der Meere, die von den Menschen ausgeht, wenn man in bestimmten Regionen sich die Zusammensetzung der Tiefseefänger ansieht. Also es gibt einige Regionen im Mittelmeer zum Beispiel, die aufgrund der vielen Schifffahrtswege so zugemüllt sind, dass also im Rahmen des Zensus of Marine Life dann auch wissenschaftliche Projekte komplett verändert werden mussten, und diese Projekte dann den Schwerpunkt Müll bekommen haben und eben sozusagen eher erforscht wurde, welche Organismen kommen denn überhaupt noch mit dem Müll vor? Wenn man die Proben hochgeholt hat, war eigentlich der größte Teil Müll und nur noch sehr sehr wenig Tiere da. Welche Tiere kommen überhaupt noch vor? Welche Bestandteile in dem Müll finden wir?
Und dann hat sich eigentlich auch erst, sage ich jetzt mal, im Prinzip diese Folgeforschung, was passiert eben mit dem Müll, sukzessive entwickelt. Das ist in den letzten Jahren eben auch sehr populär geworden, überhaupt an Müll und Mikroplastik zu arbeiten.
Das heißt das wird jetzt quasi ein eigener Wissenschaftszweig, der sich hier entwickelt?
Ja also es gibt viele Wissenschaftler, die also speziell an Mikroplastik arbeiten. Wir werden jetzt auch einen Wissenschaftler mitnehmen auf die Expedition in den kurilen Kamtschatka-Graben, der sich entsprechend die Sedimente auch ansehen wird und versuchen wird zu analysieren in seiner Doktorarbeit, dann in Kooperation mit anderen Wissenschaftlern, wo das eigentlich herkommt. Also was das für Substanzen sind und versuchen herauszufinden, wo der Ursprung liegt. Also um was für Plastik es sich tatsächlich handelt.
Wie ist sie denn so die Prognose für unser Meer aus Ihrer Perspektive?
Das ist sehr schwer zu sagen. Also ich denke schon, dass wir sehr vorsichtig mit unserem Meer umgehen müssen und sehr verstärkt Naturschutz betreiben müssen. Auf der anderen Seite ist das Meer natürlich auch sehr groß und es ist schon so, dass es natürlich auch eine Selbstregenerierung über lange Zeiträume gibt. Also ich glaube nicht, dass der Mensch es schaffen wird, diesen Planeten zu ruinieren, aber er wird ihn verändern und das ist im Moment einfach sehr sehr schwer abzusehen, welche Folgen das tatsächlich dann für das Leben im Meer und dann in letzter Konsequenz natürlich auch letztendlich für unsere eigene Gesundheit hat. Denn also es ist ganz klar, dass Biodiversität und eine reiche Biodiversität ein gesundes Ökosystem eigentlich auszeichnet, und wenn wir die zu sehr verändern, dann bringen wir das Ökosystem ganz einfach in Ungleichgewicht. Wir wissen aber noch viel zu wenig über die Prozesse tatsächlich, die die Biodiversität bewirkt, vor allem eben in Regionen, die so schwer erschließbar sind, wie zum Beispiel die Tiefsee.
Und welche Konsequenzen da eben dann die Verschmutzung haben wird, das ist einfach momentan wirklich nicht abzuschätzen.
Wie sehen Sie denn die Rolle der Wissenschaftler an der Stelle auch zur Öffentlichkeit und zur Politik als Schnittstelle zu fungieren? Was ist denn hier die Herausforderung für Sie und Ihren Stand?
Also ich denke, es ist sehr wichtig für die Wissenschaft, den Politikern aber auch der Gesellschaft einfach aufzuzeigen, wie divers das Leben im Meer ist und wovon diese Diversität eigentlich tatsächlich abhängt. Welche Faktoren das sind. Im Prinzip ist die Klimaforschung ja eigentlich besonders wichtig für den Menschen im Bezug auf die Biosphäre. Also wir wollen versuchen, das Klima zu verstehen, weil wir eben sehen, dass es die Biodiversität auf unserem Planeten verändert. Aber es tut ja nicht nur im terrestrischen Bereich, also an Land, sondern es tut es eben auch im Meer. Also mit der Temperaturveränderung verändert sich sukzessive natürlich der PH-Wert, es kommt zur Ozeanversauerung in bestimmten Regionen, wir haben Eutrophierung.
Was ist das?
Im Prinzip einen sehr sehr starken Einfluss auf die Biodiversität. Eutrophierung im Prinzip eine sehr starke Zunahme sozusagen an Phytoplanktonblüten. Also im Prinzip dort, wo sie sehr viele Nährstoffe haben, also in küstennahen Regionen, teilweise wo dann über Flüsse zum Beispiel.
So wie Überdüngung stattfindet.
Im Prinzip eine sehr starke Düngung ja. Und es ist schon unsere Aufgabe zu versuchen, diese Diversitätsveränderung zu erfassen und ich glaube, da muss einfach in der Biodiversitätsforschung ähnlich wie in der Klimaforschung eine Verbesserung der Aufnahmemöglichkeiten erfolgen. Klimaforschung hat eben diese Möglichkeiten über Satelliten Daten aufzunehmen. Und wir müssen da in der Meeresforschung und in der terrestrischen Forschung besser werden. Wir brauchen eigentlich Standorte, wo ständig auch Monitoring betrieben wird. Wo ständig auch Veränderung tatsächlich dann wahrgenommen werden. Und da gibt es momentan noch viel zu wenig Standorte, gerade im Meer. Es gibt solche sogenannten Long Term Monitoring Stations, aber da müsste eigentlich ein dichteres Netz wirklich auch gelegt werden, um überhaupt aufzuzeigen was passiert, wenn zum Beispiel die Temperatur sich verändert.
Was passiert, wenn die Temperaturzunahme in den nächsten fünf Jahren ein Grad sein wird? Es wird ja prognostiziert, dass es bis zu vier Grad in den nächsten 100 Jahren an Temperaturzunahme geben wird und dass die eben besonders stark in der Nordhemisphäre sich auswirken wird. Besonders im arktischen Ozean. Im arktischen Ozean haben wir sehr viele Anrainerstaaten, die darauf angewiesen sind, eigentlich vom Meer zu leben. Also sehr viel die russischen Nationen, Sibirien, die tatsächlich auch, für die das Meer wichtig ist. Und da wird die Veränderung zu Rückgang in der Population vieler Organismen der Fische, damit letztendlich dann auch wahrscheinlich der Meeressäuger führen und das wird für viele Nationen wahrscheinlich dann auch zu Problemen in der Ernährungsbiologie führen.
Grönländer zum Beispiel sind einfach darauf angewiesen, tatsächlich Robben zu jagen. Das gehört einfach sozusagen zu ihrem Überleben dazu.
Stellt sich natürlich die Frage, wie sich diese neuen Disziplinen und überhaupt die Meeresforschung als solche auch in Zukunft auch finanziert. Wie sie sich sozusagen organisatorisch aufstellt. Wer stützt die Meeresforschung derzeit vor allem?
Das sind eben die verschiedenen Nationen. Die Ministerien verschiedener Nationen. Was in der Zukunft sehr viel wichtiger sein wird als in der Vergangenheit ist einfach sozusagen eine sehr viel verstärkter internationale Zusammenarbeit, die ist in den letzten Dekaden schon immer nationaler geworden und es ist einfach so, dass natürlich in den verschiedenen Ländern auch unterschiedliche Geräte, unterschiedliche Expertisen existieren und da wird es immer mehr dazu führen, dass Großforschungsprojekte eben eingerichtet werden, wo dann sowohl Wissenschaftler aus sehr vielen Ländern zusammenarbeiten und dann eben teilweise eben unterschiedliche Geräte und unterschiedliche Expertise mitbringen. Also Forschung wird eher interdisziplinär und international in den nächsten Dekaden ausgerichtet sein als national.
Ja Frau Brand, ich habe so den Eindruck, das ist so ein Thema, da könnte man jetzt noch ein paar Stunden in verschiedene weitere Bereiche abtauchen. Da bin ich wieder mit meinen Meeresvergleichen. Aber an dieser Stelle denke ich bedanke ich mich erst mal für die Ausführung. Und damit kommen wir hier ans Ende unseres Gespräches und ich bedanke mich natürlich auch fürs Zuhören hier bei Forschergeist. Bald geht es wieder weiter. Ich sage, tschüss und bis bald.